are you able to create motion design  that you see in your head or do you  struggle with turning vision into  reality you may think that you need to  attend art school or that searching  YouTube for countless hours will teach  you what you need to know but you don't  what you need is a mentorship and  training program built for aspiring  motion designers just like you and it's  called style craft my name is Cameron  I'm a pro motion designer with over 20  years of experience I didn't go to art  school and I didn't learn from YouTube I  spent two decades learning how to become  a pro motion designer and I turned this  knowledge into style Graham this isn't  an online course that just teaches you  how to push buttons style craft is an  engaged paradigm shifting mentorship  program that will teach you how to  master cinematic motion design join  today and find out what it feels like to  unleash unstoppable talent